okay this is a huge deal so we're gonna
spend some time on this
donald trump admitted during one of his
weekend press briefings from his club in
bedminster new jersey
where he gathered a crowd of supporters
to cheer for him during a press briefing
and to boo reporters i mean
this is it's complete the country is
backwards right now okay
uh he said he is going to be
permanently cutting funding to social
security
and medicare how did he say it take a
look because it might not be obvious
if i'm victorious on november 3rd i plan
to forgive these taxes and make
permanent cuts
to the payroll tax so i'm going to make
them all permanent wait a second
did he say social security there how
what how is this about social security
let me explain it to you donald trump is
finally admitting here
that if he is re-elected he will
permanently cut
the employee side of the social security
deduction from wages
this is how social security is funded
this is a huge red alert this is not
getting the attention it deserves and
what's crazy is
you still have some people including
people on the left
saying biden will cut your social
security if he's president
not something biden has even talked
about for 27 years
since 1993 during which he said he
wouldn't preemptively take it off the
table
this is donald trump saying i am going
to permanently reduce
the money that is the primary funding
source
for social security so let's talk it
through earlier in the pandemic donald
trump started talking about
waiving the so-called payroll tax for
employees through the end of the year
that tax is shared between you and your
employer
if you are self-employed you pay all of
it but for most people
they're a w-2 employee for example like
producer pat
pat pays 7.65 out of his salary
and then i put in another 7.65 percent
for him it's a total of 15.3 percent
it's mostly social security and a little
bit for medicare that's how we
fund social security so trump floats the
idea hey pandemic
economics or disaster let's put more
money in people's pockets
by cutting the 7.65 percent
paid by the employee immediately the
employees get to keep another
7.65 from every paycheck great but
the way that it was originally conceived
was a deferral
meaning you get that money in your
paycheck through the end of the year
but when you file your taxes in 2021 for
2020
you owe that back it was just a deferral
it gets added back in
wasn't even permanent it's a temporary
savings and then you get a bill for it
now trump is again going for the payroll
tax idea he's looking at it via
executive order which he said when
barack obama was president is being
overused that he wouldn't do things
through executive order he'd do them
through legislation except he's not
doing it
but except he says he'll give you the
payroll tax deferral for now
if he's reelected he will forgive
the repayment of the payroll tax we
think i mean it's so convoluted that
even trump has gone back and forth on
some of these points
but now again he says in the future if
he's re-elected he will just
cut the employee side altogether here he
is
saying it again if i'm victorious on
november 3rd i plan to forgive these
taxes and make permanent cuts
to the payroll tax i'm going to make
them all permanent i plan
to forgive these taxes and make
permanent cuts
this is a shadow plan to cut
social security and medicare this is a
red alert
republicans already say social
security's in trouble it's underfunded
it won't be able to pay benefits
what do you think happens if you cut the
money going in
you obviously will have to cut the
benefits so now we have a dramatically
different proposal from donald trump
versus
joe biden on social security trump wants
permanent cuts to social security taxes
meaning
he will have to lower social security
benefits he's looking to neuter social
security
a fabric of our country really it's i
mean you know other countries have much
stronger social safety nets one of the
things we have
one of the few things is social security
trump wants to neuter it
biden wants to uncap social security
taxes
above 400 000 normally you only pay
payroll tax
on the first 130 000 or so of earnings
that means if you normally earn a
million dollars
you only paid the social security tax on
the first 130 k
above that you pay zero biden's idea is
you pay on the first 130 there's then
like a donut hole
between 130 and 400 but starting at 400
000
a year in income uncapped you pay that
7.65
that's a huge increase in funding for
social security
versus donald trump saying he will
permanently
defund it this is a topic which
is not getting huge air time right now
and we need to
force it to get more attention hopefully
it will be a big part of the debates
between trump and biden if they happen
because it is of such huge significance
to the vast majority of the united
states just think back
trump was supposedly the economic
populist big populism wonderful
populism from donald trump he is now
saying if you re-elect him
he will neuter permanently social
security
and you can take to the bank the
realization that shortly thereafter
they're going to say hey
we gave you the payroll tax people are
getting the money up front but
we're going to have to cut social
security benefits as a result we're no
longer funding it
to the extent that we previously were
don't allow this issue to be ignored
democrats need to run hard with this all
the way to november and you know that
republicans would do the exact same
thing
if democrats suggested even smaller
changes
to programs they believe are important
this is an attempt at a massive
destruction
of one of the most important programs
that exist in the united states
to even maintain financial solvency for
so many millions of americans once they
hit retirement
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video